chaque matin c'est le même rituel didier
comment seule journée de travail par la
cueillette des fruits mûrs des gestes
précis acquis au fil des semaines
dans les allées de plantation aucun
quatre fois par semaine le lundi le
mardi le jeudi et le vendredi
ça prend la matinée ici les tâches sont
effectivement variés et répétitive on
pourrait presque dire que c'est une
lutte perpétuelle pour maîtriser le
développement des tiges et la pousse
régulière des fruits didier s'en est
rendu compte avec l'expérience
ça fait trois ans et comme tout de vous
on m'a dit que l'on recherchait des gens
ici belges venus déposer un cv et puis
voilà
une fois les casiers de son chariot
rempli il les apporte dans la salle de
peser et de conditionnement puis
continue son travail jusqu'à épuisement
défraieront ensuite il rejoint les rangs
cette fois pour effectuer les feuillages
basse et pour que les tomates mûrissent
plus vite
faut que tu de l'acea soit fait en une
semaine ce que fur à mesure on taille
les grappes et fur à mesure mais faut
descendre les pieds comme ça elles sont
plus basses et on peut on peut essayer
cueillir quoi pendant ce temps christine
travail en hauteur et effectue d'autres
opérations indispensables à la bonne
organisation de la production en
préparant l'avenir de la récolte
toute la semaine et l'opération est
faite
on commence lundi il faut prendre 10
soit soit finie parce que toutes les
semaines on a une nouvelle grappes de
fleurs qui arrivent et toutes les
semaines il faut qu'elle soit
sélectionné le prochain bouquet qui sera
à tailler voyez il apparaît des gens et
l'ancien donc voyez la formation est
déjà fait et ça ça date d'une semaine
tous ces gestes répétés avec des
salariés
attentif au moindre dysfonctionnement
permettent ce résultat impressionnant de
tomates vertes des rouges de toutes
tailles qui pousse en parfaite harmonie
chaque cueilleurs n'a plus qu'à
connaître la quantité de fruits à mettre
en cage est afin de faciliter au mieux
le travail de peser et de
conditionnement que nous verrons demain